hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
uh I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you see now your weeks
going I know if you're living in Boston
your weeks go pretty good if you're
living in Houston I ain't going so good
is it [ __ ] unbelievable how many
times how many [ __ ] times two [ __ ]
players on opposing teams just gonna
[ __ ] rile up the other team with some
dumb horseshit didn't you learn anything
with Erin judge and a very unerring
judge moment playing [ __ ] in New York
New York up in Boston because they what
they tied the [ __ ] series what are
you doing and then this other jackass on
Houston looking at some game film that's
where they went back to back to back on
[ __ ] what I have Aldi whatever's I
don't know what anybody's [ __ ] name
is why the [ __ ] would you do that I'm
glad you keep doing it
stupid [ __ ] moves you're the
defending World Series champions you
don't need to be going around trying to
[ __ ] troll people you carry yourself
with the quiet confidence of a champion
that's what you're supposed to do you
don't [ __ ] rile them up so they can
be in the other locker room go on tell
you some but those guys cross the hall
then I'll respect you I mean look what
did well look what he said on [ __ ] on
[ __ ] face time whatever the [ __ ]
these kids are doing and I know there's
a lot of people down at Houston going
like you know I don't but that Altuve
thing I think that was a [ __ ] homerun
you know what I agree with you God knows
they didn't have any angle where you
could definitively say it one way or
another look like he reached back into
the stands I know Kate Upton thought
that that's the way it went down and
that's good enough for me
Kate Upton said sofa players in the
stands fans are supposed to move over
those are the rules MLB shouldn't let
fans sit there they didn't reach over
the fence you know who would've thought
Kate Upton was that into the [ __ ]
game it's great anyways I thought it I
thought it was uh I mean every angle
that I saw which was not nothing
definitive I could see why they didn't
overturn it I was surprised we got that
call but that's not why the Astros lost
the game I hate when people do that well
he missed the field goal in the first
quarter and they lost by two so I mean
if he hits that then they they would the
[ __ ] game
no yeah he [ __ ] hits it changes the
whole game didn't you watch back to the
future you can't go if you can't go back
changing things it changes the future
reason why you [ __ ] lost is because
you let up eight runs why did you let it
bake runs because you run [ __ ] social
media [ __ ] amping up the red sox they
got a little more spring in their steps
gonna I'm sorry
did they not respect the fact that we
won a hundred and eight [ __ ] games
and then Jackie Bradley jr. got to go up
then give the old right there Fred what
does um anyways I still you know I still
think this thing is far from over
alright you probably thinking hey Bill
you're up three games to one why would
you say that because I remember 2004
when there was a [ __ ] 200 million
dollar team up three games to none and
they did win so and still we till we put
the final nail in the [ __ ] coffin you
know that's it and by the way who is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and how the [ __ ] did you
figure out how the [ __ ] did they figure
out the name of the guy some random
[ __ ] guy not one credit on IMDB how
did they find out what his [ __ ] name
was and then why would you go ahead and
publish it after what happened to that
poor bastard uh what's his name Oh Mikey
Michaelson up there in the Chicago Cubs
that guy went [ __ ] him and four other
people I reached up for the ball he just
so happened to hit him whatever the hell
his name is I'm glad I forgot what his
[ __ ] name is I hope that
guy has been able to move on with his
life the guy to hide [ __ ] hide under
the old Comiskey Stadium for the last
[ __ ] I don't know 15 years now that
the Cubs want it will you finally stop
taking your childhood out on this guy
that [ __ ] guy in the front door did
what everybody else would do do you
realize the balls it takes the [ __ ]
stick your hand out there you ever see
ever like you have a foul ball something
that's a [ __ ] baseball would you go
play baseball with your friend the guy
who's just building an app with nope
with no glove would you do that be the
guy the [ __ ] alone that's like some [ __ ]
that morning [ __ ] radio guys trying
to be edgy they're the kind of people
they [ __ ] put the person's name out
this poor bastard goes look II you know
I got to get security
the Astros lose this game I'm going to
need security escort me out of here
the Astros don't come back and win this
match this [ __ ] that's pathetic
you know what about the other pitchers
giving up all those runs huh do they
have security escort them out of the
building
well I guess they do how about that
Casper been attending to end the game
un-fuckin'-believable so having said
that the Houston Astros still scared the
[ __ ] out of me because they are the
defending World Series champions they've
had a couple of [ __ ] you know tough
games here but I think of Berlin it's
gotta be coming back any moment to put
on his white hat and come back in and
save the day try to make it 3-2 then all
of a sudden they're like why you know
all we gotta do is win one more now it's
[ __ ] tied up and it's anybody serious
that's how quickly it can [ __ ] turn
around it's no different than getting
married you know you're a single man you
got the world by the balls in any second
you could just fall in love with the
woman and all that freedom you had all
that time all those great feelings you
felt about yourself all those dumb
sports shorts shorts sports shirts that
you had that you thought were cool all
of a sudden they just disappear you're
just like you're in seventh grade I
liked seventh grade
honey just try on this button down and
it all [ __ ] goes away don't ever
forget that you know it's like a [ __ ]
squirrel
alright goes over it gets a couple of
nuts it's [ __ ] lollygagging across
the road
and all of a sudden a hammer comes along
right just [ __ ] flattens the thing I
don't know I'm talking about right now I
just can't
I'm just stunned that we're up three
games to one
hopefully Joel Olsteen will [ __ ] open
the doors to his church and let some
people in there you know let that guy
[ __ ] hide in there Joel open the
[ __ ] door I need security
is it raining out Jesus doesn't want you
to come in if it's raining out um all
right enough of that [ __ ] we still got
one more to go I haven't said that I
still love the [ __ ] Astros and I love
their fans its lights I haven't seen
them this [ __ ] amped up you know
since those great late 70s teams but
junior Richards and all that and I love
when I see the old school gay pride
parade well got a flag that they used to
have it was actually more like the gay
pride like ginger flag like if you were
if you like gay people but only
redheaded once that was like what you
had a flag for it that's what their
Jersey looked like all right here's one
for you I've been in New York City I
mean I'm in Baltimore now baltimore
scarface reference anybody i got two
shows tonight at the lyric theater and
then I [ __ ] got Atlantic City I got
two more and then I see my daughter for
the first time in a week this has been
[ __ ] brutal but I had to do it cuz I
gotta [ __ ] try and uh you know I
gotta hike these goddamn gigs so anyways
I'm doing the whole [ __ ] run
yesterday sixteen at 6:15 in the morning
until 7:00 at night just running my
[ __ ] Yap about Madison Square Garden
and dude every [ __ ] every almost
every [ __ ] interview almost every
[ __ ] interview is just like so what
do you think about louis c.k coming back
you know
it stand up as a predominantly white
which would you say that it's a
predominately white male patriarchal
[ __ ] well what do you feel is an
abortion it's like what am i [ __ ]
running for office here you know all
these [ __ ] comedians that want to
talk about that [ __ ] just cuz they're
talking about all of that [ __ ] and
getting all political and [ __ ] diving
into this dividing the country down the
[ __ ] middle I'm just sitting I think
why do I have to why do I have to
comment on this so all I'll let you guys
on and little [ __ ] it inside I think I'm
sorry I don't have my microphone so
sorry about the [ __ ] breathing on
them like there I'll let you in on a
little [ __ ] secret this is how I
handle those questions they'll go like
so what do you think about louis c.k
coming back I just go I don't know what
do you think about it it [ __ ] works
every time either they either they go oh
no I'm asking you I'm like well I go I
wasn't thinking about you you're
obviously thinking about it you
obviously have an opinion I would love
to hear your opinion that fascinates me
what do you think about it
or you just go I don't know what do you
think about the book you know I think it
just it's fine I mean all right think
it's [ __ ] or whatever and then I
just sit there and I look over and I
[ __ ] look at my butt you know the guy
taking me around the radio and I just
smile up the [ __ ] do I think well I
think I want to be still be able to make
my mortgage this month if you don't mind
okay it's [ __ ] unbelievable I don't
understand how this is a more
progressive era where and things are
getting better that if if you haven't
done anything even if you comment in the
wrong [ __ ] way all of a sudden you're
in trouble and they take your [ __ ]
show away I just isolate it's it's
[ __ ] ridiculous and I know that I am
in the massive majority when I say that
jesus [ __ ] christ the amount of
people that i saw on this [ __ ] trip
that old friends I haven't seen yeah you
know women are you go to hug him you
like uh-uh
this you know the fire I want I want a
couple to [ __ ] me to stick you with
the thing when you're going for the hug
and then if you feel [ __ ] weird it
just [ __ ] it's like a nerf stick or
something it just shoots out between the
two of you I'm bringing back the fist
bone you know in this current comedy
climate what do you think is it is it
community your various current time if I
hear that one more [ __ ] time it's
like what [ __ ] shows go to a comedy
show
people are just showing up and they're
laughing they're adults they know you're
there at a show yeah you know these
[ __ ] [ __ ] what kind of a [ __ ]
adult goes to a comedy show and then
goes you know I was triggered by that
joke you were triggered well toughen the
[ __ ] up stay home all right go go watch
out Willie walk in the gin in the
[ __ ] Chocolate Factory go watch that
[ __ ] go out go go [ __ ] home and go
watch a muppet movie okay you went
outside you went in public you set
[ __ ] down in a comedy club it's the
job of the comedian to say crazy
outrageous [ __ ] and make you laugh you
know go to [ __ ] Ice Capades that's in
a close of those you know usually when
they have the star the star of the thing
is usually a [ __ ] Olympic gold medal
winner way back in the day the [ __ ] was
their name Donna Karen who was that
chick of one in 76 I remember she called
in sick the day we went to go see
Dorothy Hamill there's a great old name
huh Dorothy Dottie Dottie what do you
mean you're not [ __ ] skating it the
[ __ ] Boston Garden we gotta have a
bunch of mascots out there looking for a
pretty chick and you ain't out there
twirling around the Ice Capades trigger
me cuz my last relationship my boyfriend
was icicle to me is there any way you
couldn't melt the ice and give me my
money back
um anyway so I'm doing all this [ __ ]
doing all of this press it wasn't all
like that but there was there was a lot
of [ __ ] talking about the current
climate I'll be honest if you come to my
shows I've been going harder than ever
and I've been trashing feminists because
it's fun um and I agree with you know a
lot of this you know you want to make
sure equal I get it it's fine
does that mean I have to lose my job
because I have a [ __ ] opinion about
something huh all right there bushi
anyways so going around right and all of
these [ __ ] goddamn buildings you go
into the you know they want like an your
[ __ ] driver's license and [ __ ] like
you're going into the goddamn Pentagon
so I just show it to him and now that
they like they like take the thing from
you and they stick it in this little ass
[ __ ] computer things scan it or all
this dumb [ __ ] and you know they're
taking all your information off of it so
I have an expired license right I have
one that's not expired but I kept my
expired one and that's the one I give it
I give to him all right
it's [ __ ] from way back in the day
when I still had [ __ ] here and I had
a different address right so I [ __ ]
go to this building and I hand it to the
guy and he goes your IDs expired I go
yeah but my face is it you know I didn't
come here to drive the building you know
it's a [ __ ] ID you need an ID there's
an ID and I'm telling you these guys
pretty soon it's gonna be you need a
valid ID to go it's like you have to
know where the [ __ ] I live that goes
back to this [ __ ] guy who just like
who caught that you know that home run
and now he's sitting it going I'm gonna
meet this poor pastor's got thinking
about his own personal safety like I
don't understand how these corporations
and all these people are able to snag
your personal information people have
stalkers look at all the women out there
who literally have to have like like
restraining orders from these lunatic
guys and these [ __ ] corporations that
you're going to buy [ __ ] chapstick
you know they did they double swipe you
let whatever the [ __ ] they do with you
goddamn license they take your [ __ ]
information and they just put it out
there and you know what's gonna happen
is somebody's gonna get [ __ ] killed
because of it and then these
corporations they're not gonna be
responsible
i I don't know I don't know I'm just
basically I'm just [ __ ] I'm shouting
into a tornado here nobody gives a [ __ ]
NFI you dumb [ __ ] are gonna go under
than ancestry.com and then we're all of
our [ __ ] DNA is gonna be mapped you
know what I mean like in what what good
is gonna come with that they'll catch a
couple of serial killers okay what else
are they gonna do I'm telling you I'm
doing that whole bit they gotta [ __ ]
build your robot replacement know who
knows what I don't know I just don't
understand what people have against
privacy now you know it's [ __ ] you
see the look of concern of this guy's
this guy's [ __ ] poor bastards face
it's poor guy in Houston he's probably
thinking how the [ __ ] am I gonna get to
my goddamn horse and ride out of [ __ ]
town without these [ __ ] getting
a posse together coming after me um
anyways I don't know when the next game
is but uh people can we can we try to
stop yelling at each other you know can
we [ __ ] stop trying to peer into
everybody's [ __ ] living room these
[ __ ] lunatics like that [ __ ]
Alexis [ __ ] what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
gets that you're literally bugging your
own house house sorry I was yelling at
the TV last night watching the game
you literally bug in your own house
you're sending your DNA into the [ __ ]
Internet I don't know what else you
gonna do you're gonna [ __ ] handcuff
your wrists to your ankles start walking
backwards down the street and see what
happens I mean what are you doing
it's it's just so you can have some
[ __ ] thing and you goddamn house you
can be like you know captain and
Tennille what was the captain's Alexis
what was the captain's real name dude
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that I say when I'm in
my house to try and make my wife laugh I
mean I don't anybody hearing that I mean
that's that's our own private [ __ ]
jokes didn't forget about when I get to
a goddamn argument the [ __ ] that I say I
said why the [ __ ] would you did
somebody's recording that who's
listening to it but this got to be
somebody on the other side that Alexis
Alexa whatever the [ __ ] it is is
literally listening to your life like a
reality show you know maybe it was like
an FBI guy or a [ __ ] one of those
international [ __ ] gumshoe guys and
they're listening maybe he said a couple
of [ __ ] uh you know you were trying
to talk about former President Obama and
you said Osama instead and that was a
trigger thing so now they got to listen
in on your life to make sure you're not
[ __ ] you know a terrorist or some
[ __ ] right and then they just I don't
know they're just listening they don't
hear any terrorist [ __ ] but they just
kind of get into your life
oh he's yeah they were expecting a child
this is all this is so exciting so sick
of being in this van and he just [ __ ]
listens you know do you like like one of
those flat-screen TVs you know they got
the cameras on it like they got they
asked them do you watch people in their
houses watching TV and I don't know why
they didn't just say no they would like
you know we're not gonna comment on that
or something let me let me [ __ ] look
that [ __ ] up here we go
what is it right here
Smart TVs watch you watching you all
right here we go this ought to be great
for my [ __ ] paranoid
paranoia self destroy yeah you're smart
TV is watching you watching TV consumer
report finds now why isn't this a
concern to anybody you know your Smart
TV is watching you watch TV consumer
report finds all right millions of Smart
TVs sitting in family's living room are
vulnerable to hackers taking control oh
this is saying hackers and could be
tracking the households personal viewing
habits much more closely than their
owners realize according to a new
Consumer Reports investigation all right
so this is talking about hackers then
that's I'm talking about the actual
[ __ ] companies
all right so if hackers like wanna this
is like [ __ ] I mean that's second
that's has to be a crime right
I don't know these [ __ ] lawyers these
days is so goddamn lazy back in the day
if someone wanted to won't look at you
they had to walk up to your window right
and you saw him coming up your yard but
they're [ __ ] dick out and you had a
time to grab like a steak knife or
something or maybe a shotgun you came
out you brandished a weapon and the guy
you know ran away I mean not too fast
cuz you can only run so fast with the
[ __ ] erection and that's usually how
people got caught but now they can just
stay just stay at home
eight o'clock they start knowing you
[ __ ] habits eight just couple banks
happy Friday night around nine o'clock
when they put you know kids all go out
the kids are older sit down look at that
giant doggy style this week oh they
added something else the ripple took
this little [ __ ] TV show much I don't
know the whole thing [ __ ] freaks me
out
what what is people's fascination with
that [ __ ] why do you want to listen why
do you want to look at people what the
[ __ ] do you care maybe because I'm
antisocial I don't get it like you don't
I mean
my wife's social she says hiding the
neighbors and that [ __ ] him I'm Mikey
I'm just like hey how are you I go
inside I don't care what you're doing I
don't want to what know what you're
doing I don't want to watch you [ __ ] I
don't want to see what you eating and I
don't want gettable to see arguments I
can barely talk to you in my [ __ ]
driveway the [ __ ] would I want you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] watch that
I'm gonna learn how to hack into
somebody's TV or I could put on a Martin
Scorsese movie instead yeah man but
alexis is real man I don't know it's all
[ __ ] this old podcast the whole
thought world she's [ __ ] weirded me
out now I'll tell you this current
climate let me read this Felix Grey
which sounds like a height like a
Hollywood escort service doesn't it
Felix grey can I help you yeah I want to
read it oh and a brunette all right
Felix sorry Felix grey the average
American blast their eyes with bright
screens for 11 hours every [ __ ] day
all these things are great actually have
a pair of these he's amazing you know
now you can protect your eyes I'm not
wearing it because I'm a [ __ ] have them
at home now you can protect your eyes
with a pair of Felix grey glasses
available with or without a prescription
Felix great glasses filter out 90% of
high energy I love that percentage I
always go with that percentage 90% of
high energy blue light and eliminate the
glare coming off all those screens that
means no more tired dry eye you can't
hide your tired eyes boom-boom and your
blurry vision is the thin disc guys all
right or headaches I thought by now
sorry usually it seems like a hassle to
have to protect your eyes man and that's
why most of us don't do it but Felix
great glasses aren't like those weird
computer glasses you've seen before
there's no yellow lens tint Donny shut
the [ __ ] up that's what I always think
of when I think you
I'll have a other finger here in an hour
Felix great glasses are handcrafted from
premium Italian acetate acetate acetate
so they won't make you look nerdy in
fact throwing on some Felix Grey's is an
easy way to look pretty put together
sorry Felix Grey's glasses are available
in non prescription prescription and
rita's with free shipping and free
returns there's nothing to lose don't go
another day looking at screens without
the help of some Felix Grey's go to
Felix grey glasses calm / / to protect
your eyes today that's Felix gray
glasses GRA Y for all you dummies out
there
fel IX g ra y glasses dot-com / / there
you go
that might be my favorite Eagles song
and there's a lot of them standing on
the corner Winslow Arizona such a fine
sight to see it's an L - very [ __ ]
ball going into the [ __ ] stands hold
on baby you're out take a seat I can't
believe how many calls Boston team's
getting out it's like they're making up
for the entire last century roughing the
past or go [ __ ] yourself and your Super
Bowl dreams right then all of a sudden
but it just turned around everything
just [ __ ] has been going our way I
don't know what happened fumble by Tom
Brady Brady wait a minute the Tuck rule
you're going to the Super Bowl
Alex Rodriguez slapping that ball out of
Ming cabbage his hand
we never got those calls yeah you're out
you can't [ __ ] do that but he's
wearing pinstripes
that's over [ __ ] goddamn Canadians aw
they're losing the game I [ __ ] too
many men in the ice guila floor right
there Fred no Stanley Cup for you sir my
whole [ __ ] life
it's unbelievable I'm just going to
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it the same way
any other fan what if everything was
going his way that's another thing they
always asked me on these sports shows
don't you are you still excited I mean
with all these titles as it says it's
still exciting I mean I would be bored
well I'm not I'm enjoying the [ __ ] out
of it but thank you for your concern
thank you for asking I know it's coming
from a place of jealousy okay I know
when things are said when they're not
coming from a place of love the way Kate
Upton was Kate Upton loves baseball
who knew she an actor or shield model
she a model turned actor the [ __ ] is
Kate Upton I know that I know she's some
ridiculously beautiful woman you know
I'm more than that bill I'm also a
baseball fan sorry all right Kate Upton
Kate Upton Jesus Christ
I couldn't drama well I can't really
draw but if I couldn't draw I can't draw
a better-looking person than that what's
it like to be that good look at them you
must just like stare at yourself in the
mirror she's got the same birthday as me
oh my god maybe I have a chance Alexis
who Kate Upton go out with me
no all right Kate Elizabeth Upton is an
American model and actress Upton was
named the Sports Illustrated Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue Rookie of the
Year oh my god that's it [ __ ] over
can you imagine being that [ __ ]
good-looking if I was that good-looking
if I was like Brad Pitt good-looking I
would literally be like Ron Burgundy hi
everyone god I look I know he's have my
eyebrows up a little bit when I look to
the side you know I would be it would be
very generous with my good looks I would
I wouldn't be like one of these people
rolling their eyes like oh my god I get
it stop staring at me
can't you just Chamberlain I namib haha
I wouldn't be like that at all be
walking around half shirts and [ __ ]
eight pack everybody you take it an
anatomy class you can see Oman the
entire all the whole midsection is put
together here by the way I've been
eating like [ __ ] out here in the road my
flat stomach is no more I look like a
[ __ ] turducken all right you know
what Kate Upton looks like I look like
the exact opposite oh my god I look like
a [ __ ] redheaded Danny DeVito oh [ __ ]
I just you know I got here and it's just
like I got one of those New York deli
sandwiches and I just you know you feel
like you have to stock up because I know
I'm going back out like if I was gonna
move ever move back to the east coast
like the amount of [ __ ] Mexican food
that I would be eating in LA the amount
of taco trucks that I would hit the
amount of Thai food the amount of
burgers everything that LA does great I
go up to San Francisco I get a couple of
thousand [ __ ] burritos shove him down
my fat freckled [ __ ] throat you know
and then that would be it
and I would just head back east and I
would never get another [ __ ] taco
it's like I'm not doing it
I mean pizza how do you lay off pizza
and Italian food when you're back here
cuz I can't do it because I got to go
back to to no-man's land of [ __ ] bread
[ __ ] dough and all of that stuff so
whatever I'll get back on the diet I'm
gonna do that well three-day water fast
you know where you just drink water and
you don't consult a doctor and then all
of a sudden you go into convulsions and
then you come to in the hospital and
there's some guy [ __ ] the stethoscope
standing over you going that was a
pretty reckless thing you did what
happened well you let your electrolytes
get down to uh she challenged me when
your bile juices and what happened was
the lining in your cell walls if you
drink too much water hey buddy could you
just [ __ ] am I still alive right now
or my own health because I don't know
what the [ __ ] you talk
about okay I get it can I see a merit
but see how much weight I lost how long
were they in a coma for was it like a
liquid diet
you couldn't force me to chew are you
I'm a big Hollywood phony I don't care
if I almost killed myself I'm just
trying to lose weight I'm trying to keep
my Michelin tire [ __ ] do you know
what somebody told me I didn't know
Michelin stars were the same people who
make the tires for those of you
uncultured people a Michelin star the
coveted Michelin star you know if you
get three of those which is such a weird
thing because it's usually usually have
to get like four five star hotel you
know five star hotels then this is the
new four right but Michelin it's like
three stars it's got three Michelin
stars and that means that the food
evidently is out of this [ __ ] world
okay and I found out that I I thought it
was separate you know like this is the
Macintosh stereo and then there's the
Macintosh computer and they're spelled
differently and they have nothing to do
with each other that's what I thought a
Michelin star wars like yeah I mean but
it's not literally the [ __ ] Michelin
tire people it is and this person had to
look it up because I refused to believe
it and I was just like but why the [ __ ]
are we listening to these people they
make tires you know I mean that's just a
weird thing I see tires and and then
you're into like also brakes or
something else on a [ __ ] car steering
column something in the tire area you
know how the [ __ ] do you go from radial
tires helping me not hydroplane to beef
bourguignonne off like where the [ __ ]
I'm supposed to go to who the [ __ ] just
Michelin think they are and in
furthermore what's wrong with all of
these [ __ ] what do you call them the
goddamn chef's getting all [ __ ]
nervous about what a tire company thinks
that would be like a bunch of comedians
getting nervous about making one
comedian make them [ __ ] nervous speak
any code here okay anyways ladies and
gentlemen that is the podcast I got two
shows tonight here in Baltimore if
you're in the area come on down and then
I have two at the Borgata and then I'm
flying home immediately
that goes hang out with my lovely wife
and my beautiful daughter and I ain't
doing [ __ ] until the following weekend
and even then I'm only leaving for one
day okay and then I have Madison Square
Garden on Wednesday November 7th and
then I have three days at the
unbelievably beautiful Chicago Theatre
and then you know something old freckles
[ __ ] year on the road is over except
for one charity gig I have to do other
than that I'm done all right and I am
going to get myself I'm gonna lose these
this [ __ ] ten pounds that I think I
put on in the last three days oh I had a
good time I had a good time doing it
though you know there's a few places
that I go back to and it's like I just
go back to where the [ __ ] I were like
whenever I go back to Boston it's just
over I go to all the places that I went
to when I when I could eat McDonald's at
4:00 in the morning still wake up and
not have no damage done really and when
I go to New York I just like I'm not
gonna get a bacon egg and cheese
sandwich on a [ __ ] roll every goddamn
day how do I lay off that well bill you
have willpower
I know [ __ ] I'm streaky that's how I
am all right anyways go Red Sox go
Patriots go Bruins go Celtics this is
this great time of year where they're
all playing at the same time astro fans
be nice to that guy all right he did
what we all would have done I would have
done the same [ __ ] thing actually me
I would have got out of the way because
I want to get hit with the [ __ ] ball
but don't don't don't be a bunch of
[ __ ] all right if you take anything
from this podcast how cool is it the
Kate Upton likes [ __ ] baseball of
that level you know it's about time one
of these swimsuit models in Sports
Illustrated actually watched sports
well great though I'm sure she's [ __ ]
thrilled that she has your approval all
right please enjoy the music on the
podcast here and that's it and then
we'll play another half-hour of greatest
hits from a Thursday afternoon broadcast
just before Friday with the Monday
somewhere in there from earlier this
year or maybe
[Music]
I love you
all right long distance hiking the last
week I mentioned that I went on a hike
and we just kept going and going like
[ __ ] not realizing that we had to
walk back hiking is not like a treadmill
you don't just get to step off and be
like oh I'm still despite the fact I
walked for an hour I am still only you
know ten paces from my foot in the
parking lot in my car we ended up going
on like an 11 mile hike and it was
exhausting to say the least so this
person is writing about long-distance
hiking another great old man thing to do
yoga hockey ice hockey and hiking you
know all right hey Bill I've been
listening to your podcast long enough to
know that you love hiking you hate
getting fat and you get easily annoyed
by day-to-day [ __ ]
I really think you'd enjoy backpacking
out Jesus backpacking I know it's
awesome but can you call it something
else
backpacking I just feel like I'm [ __ ]
waiting for a bus picking my nose about
ready to get this [ __ ] kicked out of me
hey you guys want to go backpacking it's
a pack you put on your back and you go
backpacking or long-distance hiking okay
let's call it that it's a really a
long-distance hiking freaks me out
because that figure at that point you've
walked long enough to run into something
that can maul you to death
slash rip your face off or at the very
least just sort of bite your throat
until it stops feeling the pulse you
know start getting into that next weight
class of animals I don't know you know
mountain lions black bear grizzly bear
[ __ ] anaconda whatever exotic pet
that somebody let loose that has no
natural enemy that is now taking over
the forest long disor long distance
hiking it's really it's really freeing
to walk away from civilization for a
week or more with the solid pair of
boots and everything you need
rap to your back dude [ __ ] that your
mole man or woman that I am I can't
[ __ ] deal with that
I get scared I get I get freaked the
[ __ ] out I'd have to be out there with
somebody who knew what they were doing
who had a gun automatic to not even
semi-automatic I need something that I
can spray in the general direction of
the sound I just heard and you know if
we kill a couple of backpackers there's
no one else around burying them is
optional I would say leave them above
ground because they'll get picked away a
lot quicker then people will find their
clothes
I guess the bones would be there that's
creepy
see what happens when you go out in the
wilderness you start [ __ ] talking
about [ __ ] like that I live in a suburb
okay there's plenty of people to shoot
and I never think of doing it they're
right out there right [ __ ] out there
and I never think of shooting them all
of a sudden you get me backpacking or
long-distance hiking and I'm trying to
think out of bury bodies alright every
time I finish a long hike I come back
looking healthier and leaner and feeling
refreshed yeah cuz you're out there
eating berries wiping your ass with
[ __ ] pine cones that's that that's
why you have that peculiar look on your
face no matter how much you eat on the
trail you're guaranteed to lose weight
if you spend six hours a day hiking with
a 35 pound backpack there's no need to
limit yourself to salads and juice I
can't tell you how many times I've had
older day hikers look at my backpack and
tell me they wish they had done more
backpacking when they were able to it's
a really unique experience experience
out there on your own yeah I bet it is
well what can you please write back and
tell me what you do about animals man
because I'm tell you right now I'm not
doing this you know the only way I would
do this is I was in a [ __ ] platoon
and we all had machine guns just in case
I missed anyways oh here he goes he's
gonna calm me down and it isn't nearly
as dangerous or as difficult as people
make it out to be if you stay on the
trail you'll usually run across an
the hiker every few hours oh that's
comforting that's comforting every
couple hours I can run into Johnny
Appleseed but during the other hour and
fifty minutes I'm on my own all right
now you're running that usually run into
another hike or every few hours that can
help you if you get hurt and bears
mountain lions and all those other
beasts kill a lot fewer people than Los
Angeles traffic accidents do well I used
to do a bit on that well obviously
because the [ __ ] you know that
there's you're running into one person
every two hours sir let's do the math
here okay here's the deal
there's like 7 million people in Los
Angeles ok
you can't [ __ ] go anywhere without
running into like a thousand [ __ ]
people out here you're somewhere where
you walk every two hours and run into
one human being so obviously I can
guarantee you if those lions and
mountain lions were down here the death
rate would be through the [ __ ] roof
all right this is the guy this is what
he says - he goes just keep your food
away from your tent and you'll be fine
do you understand sir that you're
telling me to do something where if I'm
too near my food supply I could possibly
get eaten to death you want me to leave
my living room you know why can't I just
sit on my back porch listen I would love
I would love to to go hiking like that I
really would but I cannot get past no I
don't think you should be able to get
past it that there's that type of [ __ ]
is out there all right and if you get
mauled to death as a stand-up comedian
you know it you really were just looking
for trouble weren't you that's you know
somebody just asked me to do a cruise to
do stand-up on a cruise and I told them
I wasn't going to do it
and they said why not and I said because
I'm terrified of the ocean okay that's
why I don't I I respect it the ocean is
not the ocean it is the ocean but it's
it's literally you're talking about its
outer space on earth that's what it is
okay you can't breathe in it you're nuts
you can't be in it
if you're in it too long you're either
gonna get hypothermia or something's
gonna come up and take a bite out of yet
to see if you're edible or are you gonna
drown those are your three [ __ ]
options and I know what you're thinking
dude Cruz is a safe man you're out there
on this big [ __ ] boat yeah and until
you're not until you're not and then you
proceed to die one of the slowest most
terrifying [ __ ] deaths that there is
treading water in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere and somebody's gonna die no
matter how fast they can [ __ ] get you
out there somebody is gonna die and
people follow I [ __ ] with did one
cruise in my life and I could not I
couldn't get past the fact that I was on
something that the second it [ __ ]
shits the bed and I know you guys think
that you oh I've been on cruises and you
go [ __ ] yourself I talked to the band
that was on this cruise ship for [ __ ]
years and they told me stories over a
little [ __ ] plate of jell-o late at
night those awful cruise deserts some
poor excuse for [ __ ] I also I don't
like [ __ ] going out there and all of
a sudden it's maritime laws and this
douchebag who didn't even run for office
is now telling me what the it's whatever
he says goes with his stupid ass [ __ ]
outfit go [ __ ] yourself
they told me stories okay
they told me they told me enough [ __ ]
stories about food poisoning about [ __ ]
backing up about one engine not working
and now they're going half-speed and
then they don't make it to all the
cities and then they make up [ __ ] about
hurricanes and then they have [ __ ] it
trust me people having medical issues
and having to be [ __ ] helicoptered off
and flown as quickly as humanly possible
not to the best possible Hospital to the
nearest one all right you're going on a
cruise they go all over the [ __ ]
world
and they go by a bunch of [ __ ]
countries that you wouldn't want to
[ __ ] get em I've have a goddamn
hangnail in but all of a sudden they're
the closest one and that's where the
[ __ ] you're going Dole hey dr. Harry
hack it off [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
alright [ __ ] combines stand-up comedy
in Waterworld I'm not doing it
alright so that's the thing about I
would absolutely love to go backpacking
I would love to do that I would love to
go up [ __ ] mountains I would love to
do that it's way better than going to
the gym I understand 100% what you're
talking about but dude that [ __ ] will
you run into a bear mama bear and it
just turns around and just runs at you
3540 miles an hour you basically and
you're sitting there hearing this this
beast like trees getting out of the
[ __ ] way it's this thing is just
coming flying down the [ __ ] hill at
you and you're running knowing you're
gonna get caught and you're hearing your
stupid pots and pans calling clanking
together and all you're trying to do is
just get out in front of your friend so
he's the one that goes down and so you
can live knowing for the rest of your
life what your strategy did killed your
friends here in his cries boom
whatever the what is the sound of having
your face ripped off
now I like to lose weight like the next
guy
Jesus growling go out there with your
beer be a [ __ ] bear mace [ __ ] all of
that bears mountain lions poisonous
snakes what about if you just and then
all the [ __ ] varmints out there I
love that word because that you sent me
Sam's the only person I ever heard use
it and when I found out it was actually
a credible word and not something made
up I absolutely love that word farm it's
you know Badgers Wolverines Bobcats
people look at Bobcats like they're no
big deal ever gotten scratched by a
[ __ ] house cat how bad that that
thing can [ __ ] you up with it's a little
ass [ __ ] paws all right you you want
a goddamn Lynx jumping on you going to
[ __ ] town cuz it's bored or you
freaked it out or you came near to near
something that had peed on and you have
no [ __ ] idea that's another thing
dude you're in their world
this guy actually actually respected the
fact that I said I'm not doing it but I
honestly he I think he thought it was
pretty peculiar that I wouldn't do
stand-up on a cruise I just jumped
subject sorry and and I was waiting for
him to ask me why and I would just be
like well you know would you do a
podcast you know and on a boat in a lake
that's full of [ __ ] alligators I mean
you can okay we're on the boat
everything's [ __ ] fine but it's
really it's just an unnecessary risk
that you take goes all the way back to
that [ __ ] Saints fan
he got off easy that same [ __ ] guy
put that guy with his jersey with his
video cam camera walking up to a mama
bear screaming who day who day and all
that type of [ __ ] he's worried about
getting spit in his face he would have
bare saliva all around his [ __ ] neck
Jesus Christ I've actually thought about
that like what I've do if a bear was
running right at me I just wished that I
would have the wherewithal to run right
at it
like you know if a shark was coming at
me swim right at it and as quickly as
you can shove your [ __ ] head in there
and get it over with that is the only
[ __ ] strategy were you gonna climb a
tree thing's gonna go right up that tree
do you ever see that YouTube video of
those guys sitting in the tree hunting
that bear and all of a sudden the bear
just literally runs up the tree next to
him and is like like I don't know seven
feet above them on the tree next to him
leaning out sniffing at them trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] they are and I
love how the Bears just instincts
thankfully no it's just like like with
that bear eight feet above you that's
like when you're in a the upper deck of
a stadium you know and you're shit-faced
and you get into it with somebody two
rows behind you they automatically have
the advantage because they're punching
down right you're gonna lose that fight
you're gonna fall on your back you're
probably gonna break your ankle
something's gonna get twisted as this
guy's punching down on you not just
imagine it was a bear that was a
situation these people learned you got
to check out that video this [ __ ]
bear it was on the ground and they're
whispering and their little fatigues
looking at this thing and then this
thing I don't know how it found him you
just heard and that was it over this
thing was all of a sudden not on the
floor of the forest 20 feet down it was
now eight feet above them sniffing at
them like oh is that a food source Jesus
dude you really just hit on like two
people today hit on two tremendous fears
I have being alone in the [ __ ]
wilderness and and and being out to sea
[ __ ] both of those although I want to
hear the stories if you do it you know
not if you went on a cruise I don't give
a [ __ ] going out there eating jello
the date-rape drug [ __ ] weirdo you
know to go see the reunion of Wham
Cyndi Lauper
[Music]
what's going on it's bill burn it's the
Monday morning podcast from Monday
October 18th 2010 how the [ __ ] are you
I'm actually doing this [ __ ] Sunday
night and I posted it nice and early
look at that that's a gift for you all
you [ __ ] out there bitching about how
to actually you should call the [ __ ]
Monday afternoon podcast you know I
guess maybe you have a point but you
know what about me what about my world
what about the fact that I record them
Monday morning so it's still the Monday
morning podcast alright it's [ __ ]
free I think I I don't I have the right
to name the goddamn thing speaking of
which if you'd like to make a donation
to the Monday morning podcast and
actually get a little trinket for
yourself go to them the mmm podcast calm
and get the The O'Jays ringtone for your
phone sales have picked up last week
after I kind of broke you guys balls
about saving up for [ __ ] Happy Meals
you can't even kick me [ __ ] 99
goddamn since I'm closing in this is
just like PBS I'm closing in on the
number that I need to go buy that
[ __ ] thing so I can start walking
around doing these thrinng things maybe
go to a mall and just you can listen to
me [ __ ] on people for a [ __ ] 45
minutes it's actually you know something
that's something I really want to do
because yeah I don't know I like to
think I have love in my heart but I I
don't think so but anyways it was a it
was a big week I'm just looking at who I
wrote for douche bag of the week and I
spelled her name wrong
anyways let's talk about the the week
coming up and I've actually been talking
about this [ __ ] on stage and I don't
give a [ __ ] because it's such a topical
bit I don't even know if people are
gonna think it's funny in a month but
can we please talk about [ __ ] Bill
O'Reilly going on the view I got a I got
to tell you something right now I don't
like that guy's politics I don't like
his face
he has he has that racist face you know
his when he gets mad his [ __ ] his
face gets pointy
he just looks evil he's just not a
pleasant human being whatsoever
but I gotta tell you he [ __ ]
destroyed on the view you know and I
somewhere in there was a victory for men
because he took on four [ __ ] women
they were all yelling and he got two of
them to walk off their own [ __ ] show
how do you do that as a comedian I was
embarrassed to to stand-up Kumiko max
just quit which is why I'm nominating
Joy Behar
and Whoopi Goldberg is douche bags of
the week what did you think was gonna do
you think he was gonna go no wait don't
leave that's exactly what the [ __ ] he
wanted you to do I was actually hoping
at that point that the other two women
were gonna leave and then he could just
start hosting the O'Reilly Factor on the
view that would have been he just
totally 100% dominated at the very least
that segment cuz I don't I don't watch
that [ __ ] show but just he just came
on first of all he sits down he's got on
that shiny [ __ ] Joe Pesci shoot Joe
Pesci
Pesci suit it's difficult to say Joe
Pesci suit and he's got his [ __ ] legs
spread like with his ball bag hanging
shiny ball bag he look like if you ever
see like when Kennedy debated Nixon how
if you listen to it on the radio how
everybody said Nixon won but if you
watched it on TV
Nixon was all tanned up he had his legs
crossed he looked like a winner
and Nixon sat there with his [ __ ]
legs splayed and crossed like underneath
the chair he look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what Bill O'Reilly looked like a
nice teaches he's still dominated I
loved when he turned to joy and was just
whatever I am paraphrasing here but he
was just like be quiet and learned
and she had nothing a [ __ ] stand-up
comic she had nothing the whole segment
was [ __ ] hilarious and when he goes
uh another gem of a moment was when he
goes you know a lot of people don't
realize this but 70 percent of Americans
don't want a mosque at Ground Zero and
joy goes she goes well I'd like to see
that that pole or something like and as
she's saying that the crowd is
applauding what Bill O'Reilly just said
so you really don't need to see the pole
at that point and and getting beyond
that what he really should have said was
70% of Americans don't realize that
they're not building a mosque at Ground
Zero still that they're actually making
a rec room with a ping-pong table in an
area to pray kind of like they have an
area to pray at every [ __ ] airport
you know three four blocks up the street
at a goddamn coat factory is where it's
actually being built but the fact that
he said that they're still building a
mosque and that he got an applause break
joy is so wrapped up into her own
[ __ ] opinion that she doesn't even
hear her own studio audience back up the
guy that she's trying to [ __ ] on and the
fact that this [ __ ] guy is still
putting out inaccurate information that
people are still back in it just was
[ __ ] awesome on all of those levels
and I like how Barbara Walters was old
school cool and she didn't walk off she
gave those two douche bags of the week
[ __ ] for walking off their own show and
then she got him with a nice little
classy zinger he said Bill O'Reilly's on
here this week when we come back we're
gonna talk or he's on the show today
we're gonna when we come back he's gonna
talk about his new book called pinheads
and Patriots and then she looked at Bill
and she goes at this point I I'm not
sure which you are or something like
that it was a great little zinger but
she wasn't like judging the guy I don't
know if that the whole thing was funny
and just how Bill O'Reilly is is is
viewed as this intolerant person and
then he comes on the show
of I guess mostly liberals and then they
show absolutely no tolerance for him and
then throw a [ __ ] temper tantrum and
walk off their own goddamn show I mean
you can't tell me everybody over at Fox
News wasn't literally jerking off to
that moment Bill O'Reilly bomis became a
[ __ ] rock star in that moment that
was that was like a stand-up comic
moment that he did to two comedians
which blew my mind
you know and I know I'm always trashing
the brush on this show but that really
was a chick way of handling losing an
argument like I'm just gonna get off up
in storm ax he's so used to people
paying for your drinks and holding the
goddamn door for you you actually
thought that you as an adult that you
were just gonna walk off the show and
this was gonna be this big moment and he
was gonna be like oh wait a minute let
me stop oh I loved it he was like go
ahead and leave I don't give a [ __ ] okay
I'll take over your [ __ ] show
so anyways there you go douche bags of
the week Joe Behar and Whoopi Goldberg
for walking off your own [ __ ] show
when a shiny suit [ __ ] I can't say
he's a [ __ ] because he does know I mean
look he's very read up
on that but I'm too stupid this is why I
wouldn't this is right here why I would
never engage as much as I disagree with
his opinions I don't [ __ ] pay
attention to politics at all I don't I
find it frustrating I find it to be just
a rigged [ __ ] guy I don't give a [ __ ]
you know and I would never try to as
much as I disagree with Bill O'Reilly I
would never go on his show and try to
[ __ ] one-up the guy and think I'm
gonna beat the guy in an argument about
politics it's like he's paying attention
to these politicians the way I give a
[ __ ] about football I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna win that argument I mean when
I want to bring [ __ ] Roy Jones jr.
over and start debating him and about
boxing
I know it's just it was it was [ __ ]
hilarious that the whole thing was just
it was hilarious and big big [ __ ]
victory for that [ __ ] I don't know as
a stand-up comic you [ __ ] you just
tap out that was embarrassing anyways
let's get on with the goddamn podcast
for this week um I kind of like that you
guys like that format just getting the
douchebag of the week out of the way
right off the [ __ ] bat I know a lot
of people in Denver are probably saying
that referee who called that [ __ ] pass
interference on the Jets I mean on the
Broncos put him right down there on the
goal line
did the Jets give that guy a game ball
or what that was [ __ ] hilarious
because everybody in New York wanted to
kill that ref I can't say it was just
him but I mean he [ __ ] up to pass
interference calls with the Broncos will
mug in the Jets receivers and what a
[ __ ] time for a make up call huh here
you go mark you [ __ ] he looks like
that dude from Entourage doesn't he look
I gotta extend a [ __ ] olive branch
here to the goddamn jet fans I hate to
[ __ ] say it but you guys got a good
team I'm convinced now all right and
right now you're probably rolling your
eyes and I want you to shut your green
[ __ ] [ __ ] faces for a second all
right this is what I wait till
mid-october before I start doing we're
gonna win a [ __ ] Super Bowl that dumb
[ __ ] that people do in August those
people who paint their faces and have
horns on their hats and that dumb [ __ ]
and you don't wear a shirt to the game
in November to show people how crazy you
are because you don't know how to talk
to [ __ ] women this is what's scaring
me about the Jets as a New York jet
hater is not only are they a solid team
they got luck on this side and you
[ __ ] need that all right Patriot fan
the Tuck roll pulled that one out of the
goddamn [ __ ] mothballs wherever that
one came from you need some luck and the
jet ski
real lucky when the refs finally decided
to call a pass interference I got they
got a net that's the type of [ __ ] that
happens when you win a championship I'm
just letting you know jet fans cuz I
know you don't know what that looks like
as a jet fan unless you're in your
[ __ ] 70s at this point so uh but I do
want to say this to all you kunti jet
fans and I was going back and forth with
like 20 of them this week so I'm sorry
if I didn't get back to you all are you
[ __ ] on the [ __ ] Patriots for
getting rid of Randy Moss I got a mint
our offense kind of look the exact same
you know kind of look the exact same and
look at Deion Branch caught a touchdown
[ __ ] pass and we beat the Ravens so
we're four and one I don't know what the
[ __ ] that means
our defense looked a little bit better
but I don't know this has been the
weirdest year in history for NFL
football where there's just there's
nobody dominating there's just no
frontrunner team
you know and don't sleep on the [ __ ]
Kansas City Patriots out there huh Jesus
Christ they got our old offensive
coordinator defensive coordinator our
old quarterbacks coach and they pulled
that [ __ ] play out we have [ __ ]
throw the ball to Mike Vrabel for a
touchdown
um yeah but there's there's nobody out
there rah
Steelers came back Big Ben they got him
back I stayed away from that game I
didn't bet it I was like the [ __ ]
steel has 13 points they're gonna cover
that but there was something I got my
stupid theory about division rivalry
games this is something that's
embarrassing I'm actually doing this
Sunday night so I don't even know if the
Colts won I picked the Colts but I had
the Colts given three but these were the
bets I had this week and you can follow
this all along on the mmm podcast comm
me and Paul virzi have a season-long bet
we basically we were picking three games
a week but now we're kind of addicted to
it so now we're kind of up to four we're
gonna pick for each and at the end of
the against the spread the end of the
year whoever has the the best record
wins the pot and I went four and one
last week I thought I knew some [ __ ] and
this week I got my ass handed to me the
only game I won I think is the Jets game
I took the Jets given three I just
didn't believe in Denver's [ __ ]
quarterback and but I had I had Oakland
given six going to San Francisco I just
San Francisco keeps shooting themselves
in the foot
Oakland's been paying Klan a competitive
I [ __ ] I'll take that one lost my ass
on that one and I went against my gut
that has been telling me that Tony Romo
is missing half a [ __ ] chromosome and
he despite the fact that he throws for
350 yards in the final minutes of the
[ __ ] game he just doesn't get it done
I went against that because I saw
what's-his-face Brett Favre grab his
goddamn elbow last week during the
Monday night game so I'm like he's an
old [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] how many
horse tranquilizers they give him
they're not gonna win so I lost that
[ __ ] game too man I got to admit I've
won money on the Jets two [ __ ] weeks
in a row
two weeks in a row two [ __ ] weeks in
a row so there you go so if you want to
follow along and watch our watch our NFL
picks in that type of stuff I'm actually
trying to talk less about the NFL just
because I've really that's all that I
have been talking about I feel for like
the last two three weeks so and speaking
of which I actually ran to Nick Swardson
and he asked me next time he could come
on here because he wants to scream about
[ __ ] NFL football if you guys think
that I am a psycho when it comes to that
[ __ ] this guy he really like I was
sitting I was telling him that bills you
know bills Jets game or somebody like
when I was taking a piss and somebody
almost pushed me to the wall cuz I was
running my mouth so much and I was
telling him how I was thinking back
afterwards of how I don't want to end up
with my teeth on the floor of a [ __ ]
half s NFL stadium and he was like no no
you did the right thing you did the
right thing you should have talked more
[ __ ] so I got to get him on there cuz I
think it'll be on this podcast do
another one of those special ones just
because I think it'll be interesting to
hear me tried to be a recovered angry
fan and and him saying no you got to
steer into it anyways let's get with
questions this week somebody wrote me
here and he said bill I just got the DVD
let it go in the mail and it was [ __ ]
awesome and before I even get going I
want to thank this guy for by actually
buying the DVD and I also want to thank
all you guys who went out and bought it
it was actually number one last week the
number one comedy download as far as
stand-up comedy goes on iTunes so I want
to thank all you guys it was [ __ ]
huge for me to hear that so and then as
far as comedy goes it was only behind
the soundtrack to get him to the Greek I
don't know where the [ __ ] it is now this
point might be behind some [ __ ]
nipsey Russell compilation but for one
day I was number one so please keep
buying it and everybody's saying the
same [ __ ] who has bought it they're like
wow it's even funnier than when I saw in
Comedy Central and they took out some
[ __ ]
strong bits which I really feel that is
accurate because they took out 16
minutes of the special so if you think
you saw it you still haven't seen it
it's only [ __ ] 10 bucks $10 and
change so please check it out just so I
can sell enough [ __ ] units to this
place these people I did business with
will actually get in business with me
again and want me to do another [ __ ]
special it's how it works see if they
don't make any [ __ ] money next thing
you know I will be on American Idol
sitting next to Steven Tyler and I'll be
[ __ ] I don't know watch E I guess I
would be on Last Comic Standing wouldn't
I have I said anything funny for 20
minutes let's go let's let's plow
through this anyways I just recently
started listening to the podcast and
whatever any [ __ ] ways I like a
conversational this guy writes it
listened to the podcast and [ __ ] in any
[ __ ] ways I like how you talk about
pirating music / comedy and how it sucks
ass I'm an independent musician and if I
don't sell my singles for 90 cents a
[ __ ] song my music career dies it
doesn't matter that my YouTube videos of
songs have hundreds of thousands of hits
or whatever actual sales mean everything
I hear you I hear you because they will
not get back in business with you um so
anyways he goes I have a question about
alcohol I don't drink that much but when
I do I drink excessively like twice a
week usually I blackout nothing bad ever
happens I just like drinking Jesus this
sounds familiar he goes on to say should
I cut back I usually clean my I usually
clean my apartment when i black out that
doesn't seem bad however most people
think I have a problem for getting that
drunk on the weekends I would appreciate
your feedback again let it go was great
worth the 10 [ __ ] dollars well thank
you once again for buying it yeah dude
alright I got to tell you uh I've
blacked out from drinking who hasn't and
I got I mean I've always been fascinated
oh the lovely knee is coming it
um I've always been fascinated it's
freezing he's freezing in here come on
the podcast for a second we'll turn the
heat on
oh Jesus you know what she just picked
up she I don't know where you got that
she bought this [ __ ] it looks like a
woolly mammoth pelt you're really into
furs huh pick up the microphone and talk
into it this week rather than me you
know this is not real okay look you come
in here all hiding it's [ __ ] gross no
it isn't yet it that looks like that
used to be in the back of a van in the
70s I bet if you put a [ __ ]
ultraviolet light over it break Brady's
jizz is on that from when he banged
Florence Henderson alright I said it I
said it it's disgusting I don't like it
but I've to you but not to the listeners
I think they need to know listen I'll be
the judge of that
okay [ __ ] it's disgusting quiet and
learn something
yeah I'm trying to see if that works on
all females miss joy just shut up you
know it's [ __ ] up I actually
douchebags of the week I actually said
Joy Behar and Whoopi Goldberg for
walking off their own goddamn show
quitting no I I said that I don't agree
with his politics but he [ __ ] was he
was the man it was their show they
should have walked out it's true it's
like you're in my house you walk off you
know what I mean that would be like
someone you had a house party and some
guy came in like break and [ __ ] was
being a dick and then to make him leave
you leave your own [ __ ] house you're
waiting for him to say no so let's get
back to this thing can you please stop
buying [ __ ] like that alright you know
what else she got I'm just really gonna
trash everything you got she
found this cheetah print I didn't find
it I paid for a yard sale you're like
[ __ ] Peg Bundy
what do you mean yours your furniture
blanket style
no it's it's Leopard it's a she found
this leopard print sort of table sort of
something that you see it's clearly the
print on is basically saying you know
[ __ ] your hoary girlfriend on this
that's what that says and she went out
she got it and I'm like yeah and I said
if you hadn't guessed no and I told you
to get the thing fumigated and you never
did fumigated whatever the [ __ ] you it
professionally cleaned listen I'm trying
to help you out if you're gonna buy
something used when it comes to it's
gonna be up against your body or
whatever the [ __ ] are you got let me
finish my stupid point okay be quiet and
learn no listen to me
if you're gonna do [ __ ] like that like
stay away from leopard prints might I
like it because that's my taste it's not
your taste and that's fine okay but it
we bought it off of some friggin yuppie
no we didn't know what you did I did
okay don't [ __ ] mention towns in
areas what's wrong with you why don't
you just give the goddamn air they live
across the street
throw them up the my one stalker okay
thank you for stopping by the podcast I
am dismissing you because you're
divulging too much information you're
cold you're wrapped up in that woolly
mammoth blanket I don't like it you're
really annoying me just get out of here
alright I'm serious I'm dead serious go
out to the kitchen and [ __ ] cook
something up whip something up there
puts
yeah you don't even believe it dude did
you turn the [ __ ] heat on cuz I smell
that burning smell when are we gonna
step up our life I should really take a
picture well this is what I want to do
I'll tell because I keep going to
people's parties and they're living
better than we are this this whole debt
free life that we're living the level of
freedom that we have like man let's go
see a movie and we don't have to we
don't have to work that we both had a
white-trash
up in my house war dress macaroni and
cheese was a main dish and you had it
with toast we eat chipped beef on toast
no but every once in a while we would
have that as a dinner and I loved it we
have chipped beef on toast what beef
chipped beef on toast
it was chips of beef from knope's beef
like if just imagine if you could freeze
a cow yeah you skinned it and then you
froze it and then you walked up to with
a hammer and chisel and you chipped up
some beef and it came in this this
mushroomy sort of oh my god what the
[ __ ] was that
oh my god what I'm trying to remember
the name last beef but it came in a
sauce yeah and there was this I'm not
really having a flashback to my
childhood we had this other meal that it
would always involve bread cuz it fills
you up and we had like two pieces of
bread it was like this mushroom me sort
of looking [ __ ] that had these little
red things in there that was [ __ ]
gross cube steaks
you'd be chewing it
you'd be chewing it like three hours
later trying to get that tendon down no
I I lived we always had food we know we
had we had her ups and down my chat was
like the economy that was booms there
was bus but unlike this country at some
point we had a level ground in that and
then yeah we leveled off around my high
school years yeah but uh but it was a
good time
but what I'm saying is you know what I'm
just saying that we're living like we're
still eating Cuse yes we are doing that
why don't we complain ooh [ __ ] table
that doesn't have just stance on stupid
trying to have style as a leopard print
leopard print equals come Nia
it equals come know that you think you
have 30 seconds to wrap this up in the
balls I will kick you what are you Yoda
in the balls I will kick you sorry
hacky and pressure already I've never
even seen that movie I've just seen
enough hack comedy if it's so
forgettable those are the most overrated
piece of [ __ ] oh you're gonna fear the
wrath of this let me take something I go
back and watch Sesame Street Kermit the
Frog is still funny timelessly
timelessly funny if you get the ones
when Jim Henson did it yes okay and at
that time you ever seen that one with
that guy comes in and they're trying to
teach about instruments and
comes into the to the music store and he
goes and he goes what can I help you
with and he goes I'd like to buy and he
sounds like a trumpet and he goes and he
goes yeah but BAP top right so you're
thinking in your head you're like oh
that's a [ __ ] trumpet and the Duke
comes back with like a like a snare drum
and he goes now I didn't ask for uh and
then he could make them they would just
have somebody play that I was teaching
you about but the guy weren't in the
story was hilarious at one point he goes
no you're one of those like he kind of
gave him a little dig like there was
there was something in there for uh for
adults and it's still funny but you go
back and you watch Star Wars unless
you're just like reliving a childhood
which I understand because I watch NFL
highlights and look at football cards I
do get that but I wasn't a sci-fi kid
but I I go back and I watch those and
they suck the acting sup doing this
movie about you know space and the
effects at the time that [ __ ] like blow
people away I thought that was the thing
for its time people were like oh my god
absolutely absolutely but it doesn't it
doesn't hold up
like it looks kind of cheesy and like
b-movie no like it sucks it's really
good what were we talking about wait no
I was I have to get back to the podcast
alright if you don't stop talking I'm
gonna walk off my own podcast that'll
show me in protei I was saying to you
their listeners out here do they know
your opinion of you know vintage or old
items like like a goodwill or a yard
sale it's [ __ ] gross you feel like
people eat people either died in it or
came on it this is seriously what Bill
things when it comes to like Vint like
it's a vintage goodwill yardsale someone
either the thing is we donate stuff to
Goodwill all the time have we done any
of those things on any of those things
that we yes yes yes no we haven't
I'm gonna tell you right now there's not
a t-shirt that I own I'm gonna give a
tuck oh how many times you've washed it
well you need to stop asking the
questions well I never
anything gross and like the clothes that
I donates a goodwill or whatever it can
be a pray all right listen if you're not
gonna be honest on the podcast look at
first of all you go down there and then
all that goddamn estate jewelry with
those brooches that somebody's dead
grandmother's stuff so that's [ __ ]
creepy so what do you people do throw it
in the trash no I don't know I'm not
people can do whatever they want
I'm just don't want you wearing some
[ __ ] Jack Klugman old trench coat
I'll [ __ ] itches it's just gross it's
[ __ ] gross we have the money to buy
new clothes go buy them I like certain
vintage clothes a lot of people do snob
about it no I don't thing it up as
having nice [ __ ] me and not grabbing a
leopard [ __ ] come table off the
goddamn sidewalk it's nice all right I
like it it brings me happiness
you don't like it doesn't mean I'm not
allowed to be happy all right you know
what you warming up you warming up your
one alright well thank you for stopping
by the podcast no I I have to get I have
to get because I already I talked to
Brett Greg Fitzsimmons on this special
one so I've already had guess I tried it
I try to do the guest thing every once
in a while and your little pouty face is
not going to influence me either way um
do me a favor go out and uh go get me
some ice cream or something
can you what's that what's that [ __ ]
that the Italians make there that
awesome stuff gelato I'm not gonna get
you gelato why because what if I ask
really nice Oh what if I ask nicely so
what if I ask nicely it's too late
you're not even asking nicely now you
haven't given me a chance
yeah it's been real listen you look so
beautiful right now
and I was wondering hey you see that's
you get rid of your girl I do was ask
her to do you a favor and they storm out
of the room so there's another one for
you all right let's get to underrated
overrated this week how far into this
[ __ ] pot 31 [ __ ] goddamn minutes
actually speaking of reliving your
childhood I actually every once in a
while go through like I I'm really big
on the NFL in the 1970s and I own
complete sets of football cards
basically from the late 70s to the early
80s which was basically when I was of
the age when I should have been
collecting football cards all the way to
the age where I was almost getting a
driver's license and it was getting a
little weird and my parents were worried
that either I was a gonna live at home
for the rest of my life or bring a gun
to school one of the other
let me get rid of this close this window
here let's get to underrated overrated
for the week here overrated underrated
overrated this person's and this is for
all any new listeners out there of my
podcast which I doubt I'm gonna have for
a while because evidently iTunes is done
with me and I know there's a lot of
people if you already subscribed this
was the confusion last week with Brad is
if you already subscribe to my podcast
on iTunes for some [ __ ] reason you
can still get the podcast each week but
if you're a new listener and you search
for the podcast it's not there anymore
if anybody knows any computer savvy
people out there knows a way that I can
guide new listeners to find where my
podcast is on iTunes I would really
appreciate it I don't know if it's
because you clicked on my website this
is all [ __ ] my web guy handle so I have
no [ __ ] idea please help me up won't
you please alright
overrated underrated for the week
overrated Lady Gaga this guy says or
this woman I have no idea why is it chic
and dressed like a slim jim mascot and
sing about being a [ __ ] tease and
everyone thinks she's brilliant do they
listen to her lyrics and stop telling me
she's beautiful on TV and in magazines
I'm sick of being told what to find
attractive I don't know where they get
their standard but this [ __ ] is ugly
granted she has a nice ass from what I
can tell by the Rolling Stone cover but
I bet it's not even her real one while
I'm at it Britney Spears is ugly too
where does the media get its taste and
women from come on man back in the day
Britney wasn't hot you know before she
went crazy and shaved her head and
robbed that 7-eleven or whatever the
[ __ ] she did you know something they
might
they might actually fix her up a little
bit because I thought that um remember
that video she did was she just wore the
Allred latex outfit she looked like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know what it was
about that was she not wearing high
heels she looked like like how she would
look like the morning after after you
[ __ ] her and you got to see what she
really looked like you know you know my
theory about the whole uh you know women
with high heels shoes and you're
thinking oh my god look at this girl she
looks like a supermodel and then you get
them home you get them out of the shoes
and after you're done doing what you do
when they get up to go get some water or
go to the bathroom you just see this
[ __ ] and a thong waddling across the
[ __ ] floor
she's that's what she looked like in
that video Wow Jesus this is why I don't
- [ __ ] this you know something for all
you [ __ ] who give me [ __ ] about how the
podcast is late every week this is why I
don't do it Sunday night cuz I'm burned
out from watching [ __ ] sports or I
floor in an airplane and it's never
funny this is the only part of the
podcast that ends up being funny is me
talking about how [ __ ] unfunny it is
alright let's plow ahead did I tell you
guys it was raining out here today and
how every douche bag out here the second
it starts raining in LA they start
driving like there's six inches of snow
on the ground evidently it's because it
never rains out here that all the oil
transmission fluid and all that just
sits there and marinates on the street
and I guess when it rains it makes it
extra slippery more slippery than it
would be in an area where it actually
rains but these [ __ ] pee it's still
not that [ __ ] slippery continuing on
these are just ideas these aren't even
jokes I'm just presenting premises that
maybe one day I'll be able to make funny
Jesus Christ
underrated pitbulls if [ __ ] burns me
up
to see all the bad press pitbulls get
because some horrible luck abused one
what get because some horrible [ __ ]
abused one into killing into a killing
machine yet again did not like that I
have one and he's a [ __ ] marshmallow
you know how since you you should know
since you have one two they're great
dogs I like most dog breeds except for
the one the the tiny ones but pit bulls
especially make great dogs they're the
chosen breed of evil [ __ ] I admit but
on their own they're nothing dangerous
it's funny to see people act worried
around my dogs sometimes but it's also
kind of sad yeah I would go with that
but also I think that you should get
some sort of training before you get
either a pit bull a German Shepherd a
Doberman Pinscher and even like a
Labrador Retriever any of those [ __ ]
dogs because I don't know they kind of
I've learned through taking my dog to
one of these Dog Whisperer people they
really feed off your vibes and as you
notice I'm sort of an angry amped up guy
so you know I'm not gonna get into the
[ __ ] details but I've had to
definitely adjust my behavior my dog's
fine now but it got a little shady there
for a second
overrated the Disney Channel as far as I
can tell on passing by this channel
sometimes it's it's a foxy gnome yawning
on the podcast this is all you [ __ ] who
give me [ __ ] every week to do it [ __ ]
Sunday night as far as I can tell on
passing by this this channel it's a
preteen porn ring they take these 12 to
14 year old girls and dress them [ __ ]
and cover them in makeup and then tell
them to act twice their age Jesus what
is with these shows where the kids are
[ __ ] 14 and they have problems I
didn't have until I was in my 20s I was
a [ __ ] when I was 14 and so is everyone
else I didn't do [ __ ] with my life then
and neither did anyone it's disgusting
and it's a farce what they do to these
girls you're making my dick confused
thinking I'm looking at a grown woman
when I'm not thank you lead me into
temptation
lead me not into temptation
Disney Channel and you wonder why there
are so many pedophiles
I don't think Disney's the reason why
there's so many pedophiles but I do
agree they're subtly making programming
for them I don't even know if that's
[ __ ] Russian team say that [ __ ] but I
will say like Calvin Klein if I was to
guess is 100% Pro pedophile and I think
that he had a meeting at some point it
was like you know what there's an entire
segment of the human population that is
not getting their needs taken care of
when it comes to advertising and that is
the [ __ ] pedophiles so with that
let's come up with an ad campaign
underrated legendary comedians bill as a
comedian yourself I'm sure you have
nothing but respect for legends like
Carlin Pryor or Lenny Bruce Lenny Bruce
but Carlin gets dismissed so often in
favor of the hacks they have out there
today
for the most part the only thing most
people know about him is that he he's
the seven dirty words guy really that's
how we honor a 50-year career of a
comedy legend with him scure bid he did
in the 70s I know there was a Supreme
Court case over it and whatnot but it
just bothers me to see how many kids
today know all about hat comics like I'm
not naming names and they've never heard
of Carlin Pryor Bruce Hicks or their
work it's nice that there are comedians
out there okay now he's complimenting me
so I can't read that [ __ ] alright um
yeah I mean it is what it is it's one of
those deals where you know I think I
knew who Carlin was when I was a kid
because he was he was at the height of
his career when I was coming up in the
70s and the 80s but I had no idea who
Lenny Bruce was until I got into
stand-up comedy that's just I think
that's just part of being young it is
annoying actually talked to one of my
cousin's the other day who's in her
early 20s and I mentioned the kids in
the hall in both her and her
my friend had no idea who or what that
was it just I don't know it is what it
is overrated beautiful women I don't
mean because they're prone to deception
I mean because some women are too
beautiful in this sort of unfuckable
kind of way
they're just ruined a woman has to be at
least a little flawed so you feel like
you can violate herself it's hell being
with a beautiful woman anyways because
you drive yourself crazy thinking
everyone wants what you have it's better
to be with someone you learn you learn
to find attractive in your own way and
no one else can see it
alright oh [ __ ]
okay lady here's his opinions that's a
self-esteem issue right there on your
part you know but I do understand you
know what it is when a girl is just so
it's not like it's a combination of
beautiful and just nice
like every met a girl who's just so
beautiful and so nice and you're so
[ __ ] up and twisted that you can't
have sex with her
you just can't you're like I don't wanna
[ __ ] you I want to take you to a movie
you know and then you meet some skank
and you're like I'm not taking you a
movie I want to [ __ ] bend you over
the dresser I believe that's a [ __ ]
Madonna complex am I the only one who
feels that way trying to think of a
somebody on TV that you could relate to
that's just nice you know who's
borderline is that [ __ ] goofy chick
who cooks Rachael Ray she's borderline
so sort of like nice and innocent that
you couldn't but it's literally that
quality that just makes you want to
[ __ ] you know
I don't know fault in it oh gee let's
continue underrated having a fun job
this one is aimed at you bill you like
to [ __ ] about how midgets insert
midgets [ __ ] stoners etc don't want to
work often enough can i clarify that
stoner thing I made fun of a specific
person a friend of mine who smokes way
too much weed and every stoner out there
[ __ ] sent me these emails we mean
what do you got against I guess cuz I
imitate you like that but what the [ __ ]
that's the standard voice for you
you find me a pop movie where someone
doesn't talk like that and I'll do a
better impression but that's what
everybody says how come you always
coming down blood hits me in I'm not I'm
coming down on my [ __ ] douchebag
friend who all he's done is smoke weed
and it hasn't been a good thing for him
his quote I like to smoke weed because
it turns my life into a movie alright
you have a problem at that point now all
you [ __ ] who like to smoke weed and
listen to this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
I drink
wouldn't that be hypocritical I'm
speaking of which I'm on the wagon again
as of today I did not drink today
everybody and I'm gonna try to see if I
can make it all the way to the Rose Bowl
before I fall off the [ __ ] work and
again yawning once again no I don't know
what it is I
I've just been eating the wrong foods
and I don't know and every night I've
just been doing sets and I've had two
Heinekens and nexi know I have this
distended white belly and I'm not liking
it you know I was just at a party and I
wasn't drinking but I was leaning up
against the counter and normally it'd be
digging into my back but I had a nice
nice level of padding you know from
[ __ ] you know it really screwed me up
was when I went to Buffalo the goddamn
buffalo wings was so good there that I
have gone on a buffalo wing kick and I
found a couple places out here that have
really good buffalo wings and actually
you want to hear the story this is what
happened I woke up on Saturday I'm you
know sad or Saturday as they say in
Boston in Boston when the real hardcore
Boston guys you know I saw him on say
you just sort of open your mouth say
Thursday Friday say Sunday say I woke up
and I'm thinking all right college
football
Auburn first Arkansas LSU's plain
McNeese State they given 39 and a half
points are they gonna [ __ ] cover the
spread
who else was playing Georgia was playing
Vander bells all [ __ ] psyched and
we're laying in bed
my beautiful girl wakes up and she said
and she claimed the [ __ ] TV it's like
I'm watching TV so I immediately got up
acted like I was going to the bathroom
and I walked out sat in the living room
and I turned on the [ __ ] TV and I
started watching who the [ __ ] was
playing I started watching the Auburn
Arkansas game which was [ __ ]
ridiculous
you know Arkansas ended up scoring like
40-something points and they still lost
by 20 it was absolutely insane and so
she's like hey I said I was gonna watch
TV yeah right so I tried the Bill
O'Reilly I try to do that and it just
didn't want didn't work all right she
had a rough week she wanted to watch her
stupid reality shows so I said fine
I said fine all right and I grabbed my
stereo one of my stereo speakers was
busted so I took it down to this [ __ ]
local guy this guy's out of his goddamn
mind
he actually repairs [ __ ] so I already
love the guy so I go down there I get
that taken care of
oh you know what else did I do I went
out I just I just fixed some [ __ ] I went
out and I bought some stuff I fixed some
[ __ ] around the apartment and I let her
watch the [ __ ] and at one point I was
picking up dry cleaning I was doing all
these goddamn chores and I just saw this
[ __ ] in this bar and I knew they had
wings and I was literally gonna go in to
get dry cleaning I was parked in the dry
cleaner parking lot and I look across
the [ __ ] way
and there's a bar with wings and I get
out like a like the Manchurian Candidate
like they just turned on my chip and I
walked across the street in the bar and
next thing you know I'm sitting there
I got a water I got a Botton's and I got
a [ __ ] order of a dozen wings and I'm
tearing these [ __ ] things down like
I'm in a wings eatin contest Here I am
consuming 800 [ __ ] calories or
whatever the hell it was 1200 goddamn
calories for no [ __ ] reason because I
don't want to bother my girl because
she's watching she's watching her
[ __ ] shows so I do all this [ __ ] I
only end up stumbling out of there and
then I finally go over to get the
goddamn dry cleaning and I come back
right and during that time a buddy of
mine texts me said hey I'm in LA are you
watching the Ohio State game I said
what's gonna be on TV why don't you come
by I figured because my girls watched
three hours of [ __ ] I have to whisper
this part she's gonna get mad I figured
because she watched three I was a
[ __ ] TV that I could actually have a
friend over but like a douche rather
than saying hey you know you watch TV
for three hours so I'm gonna have a
buddy of mine over here now and we're
gonna watch the eyes Ohio Ohio State
Wisconsin game I actually gave her the
benefit of the doubt that she was gonna
be courteous and I said hey a friend of
mine is coming over to watch the house
State game you know we can either watch
it here or would you rather us watch it
out in a bar you know because
I thought she was gonna be like well you
know I hog the TV for three hours you
know why don't you watch it here and
I'll leave you guys alone she didn't she
goes yeah go watch it as a sports bar
Sena no I was pissed you know like when
you have like one slice of pizza left
and you offer it to somebody going hey
do you want this slice of pizza even
though you want it cuz you're thinking
they're gonna go no no that's okay cuz
that's what you would say and you go hey
would you like the slice of pizza they
go actually I would and then they start
eating then you're sitting there for
you're [ __ ] mad at then we should be
mad at yourself well like an [ __ ] I
got mad at her right and we had time to
do a quick workout I just ate some
[ __ ] wings she wanted to go on a hike
so we start to go on this hike and I
just start going onto the on this rant
about the stupid [ __ ] TV shows that she
[ __ ] watched watches and we got about
a third into the hike and she was like a
wide receiver just breaking off her
[ __ ] pattern she just made her write
down that we were supposed to be walking
straight she broke off me too right
and started walking down a side street
and I didn't even give a [ __ ] and I
continued my own way and we both were
hiking separately you know broke off the
whole [ __ ] thing we end up getting
this huge goddamn argument before my
friend came over and then there was that
whole thing like a [ __ ] now I got to
patch it up before he comes over so he
doesn't feel the tension that we've been
[ __ ] arguing and not only we arguing
we're arguing about [ __ ] him coming
over so I smoothed it over she came back
I said look I [ __ ] overreacted yeah
they got it yet I didn't you have a
[ __ ] ending I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
just gonna keep saying it's cuz it's
Sunday I'm gonna read one more [ __ ]
email and I'm just gonna tap out for
this awful [ __ ] podcast what was the
point of that can anybody even remember
what where the [ __ ] was I even go I've
started talking about about eating wings
and being out of shape and then the end
of it I I told a [ __ ] half-assed
story about getting into an argument
now I can't even sign into my [ __ ]
this dis dis podcast is literally just
unraveling unraveling I don't even drink
today the [ __ ] is my podcast
hey here's a youtube video of the week
if you guys are like if you play drums
and you want to see a guy who actually
can kind of make his drums and the way
he plays sound like John Bonham's guys
does a great job look up John Bonham
swing feel feel fel and and tell me the
guy playing drums does not look like was
it ochre was the name of the [ __ ]
psycho in Revenge of the Nerds tell me
that's not him but hang on a second I
gotta get back here cuz I wanted to read
something about douchebag sports fans
and then I'm gonna end the podcast for
this week
this one really sucked but I gotta admit
the last couple weeks were pretty good
but this one this one was not good in
the annals of Bill burr podcast you know
this one will not make it to repeats if
this ever goes into syndication somebody
sent me a great [ __ ] email
oh I know why cuz I had on this page
about sports fans right I'll tell you
what is I'm searching for this [ __ ]
thing that I can't find anymore goddamn
[ __ ] here we go here's some YouTube
videos out cold reason to kill all of
these are on the mmm podcast cuz some of
these are for actually from break.com
and so rather than have to jump around
websites if you want to watch all these
out cold reason to kill this is like
inexplicable this [ __ ] video there's
a singer he's on the ground and there's
a fan doing something to him that I just
can't believe and they proceeded to have
the worst fistfight in the history of
fistfights look up Kendall on
sharecropping field trip
one slap ko at gas station that's
actually from break.com and then look up
massive knockout those things are kind
of violent the [ __ ] did I do with the
goddamn email this kid sent me this guy
sent me a great email about as much as
people hate the Patriots they hate the
Cowboys more so he actually kind of I
give up you know what I just [ __ ]
give up on this god damn podcast all
right here's what I'm gonna be this week
all right you [ __ ] pricks I'm gonna
be at the Wilbur theater in Boston
Massachusetts on Wednesday of this week
this is a fundraiser for my brothers
campaign he's running for state Senate
in Massachusetts not to be in the United
States Senate representing Massachusetts
but I guess they have a different kind
of Center too just in Massachusetts I'm
too [ __ ] dumb so whatever I'm gonna
do a comedy show at the Wilbur theater
it's my brand-new hour of material all
proceeds will go to my brother's
campaign to try to help him get elected
so come on down even if you're not in
his district which I don't even know
what the [ __ ] it is come on down
and I'm gonna be telling a lot of family
stories and trying to walk that line so
I don't offend too many people because
it is kind of a political thing and
later on this week I will be at the
Pantages Theatre in Minneapolis
Minnesota on October 22nd and the
wonderful talented teen idol sensation
from the Opie and Anthony show Joe
DeRosa will be opening for me and then
the following day we're gonna be at the
Vic Theatre in Chicago Illinois October
23rd
that show from what I've heard is
actually sold out and I think the one in
Minneapolis is coming damn close so I'm
gonna thank you guys for the ridiculous
amount of support that you've given me
and I'm gonna give you a [ __ ] hell of
a show when you come down there and I
think that's it I think that's it for
the podcast this week it is
is one of the lamest ones I think I've
ever done let me let me see if I can
just somehow pull out of it
do I got anything this thing this guy
sent me robots are stealing jobs robots
are stealing American jobs according to
MIT economist forget the recession
immigration and the mortgage industry
collapse well ok why how can you forget
all of those ok this is already a
ridiculous article but I think there was
a point to be made here when it comes to
the loss of American jobs robots are to
blame and you know it's hilarious they
got a picture of a robot with [ __ ]
arms folding a goddamn sweater that's
the conclusion of a conte economist do
you understand in the future that when
you have a robot not only can it fold
the sweaters at the gap it can also be
security you know didn't you guys see
Robocop can't you see what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen all you morons who are
using these automated checkout machines
just helping these [ __ ] guys do you
think these corporations are beyond
leading you to a shallow mass grave when
they don't need you anymore when they
figure out how to make a robot that can
actually work for free and and you can
actually [ __ ] it and it feels like a
human being when those two things come
together like when they drove that
Golden Spike in when they made the
railroads connect I'm telling you that's
the end of it for you and for me huh be
honest with yourself are you inventing
anything what do you do for a living you
think you're not replaceable thinking
you don't think they could have a robot
they just [ __ ] upload every goddamn
routine of all time and you just you can
just have like a computer screen topics
political absurd hacky what you know
women men and women dogs and cats all
that type of [ __ ] or just have it to a
Richard Pryor bit and have it move
around like Richard and they have a red
[ __ ] shirt on like that great special
he did we're all [ __ ] replaceable all
right why are you gonna help him out
anyways they say that's the conclusion
of economists who've studied labor
statistic
an increasing job polarization a growing
disparity in the pay among low and high
skilled low and high skilled jobs a
handful of studies from the spring and
summer have picked up steam in recent
weeks and they raised some interesting
questions about the economy in the days
leading up to Election Day by the way
how great have I become reading out loud
this is [ __ ] amazing now that I've
said it let's see if I'm in my head and
I [ __ ] up Manufacturing is still strong
in this country it's just that robots
not humans are the ones Manning the
factories if automation is the future of
manufacturing and medicine and other
fields less educated Americans could be
left in the dust I gotta be honest with
you I don't write but the way they just
worded that I don't know where I stand
on that
I'm definitely think the world is
overpopulated see this this enters like
that [ __ ] Hitler [ __ ] you're gonna
have to start deciding who gets to live
and who doesn't ah Jesus oh geez so I
don't know I actually took my [ __ ]
two speakers right I found this guy down
the goddamn Street somehow I'm gonna
stretch this into an hour
I got another two minutes I found this
guy down the street who I had you know
you know the thing you stick your iPod
on and it's got the speakers and that
type of [ __ ] well that think broke one
day and it just doesn't work
Sony is just like well let's just throw
it out now go no I want to get it I want
to get fixed and she's like she
literally gets like upset and I'm like
if there's probably just a [ __ ] wire
or something I just don't understand
electronics he could just open it up he
could fix it
and I find this [ __ ] guy the first
thing I did was had these old speakers
that I hook up to my laptop and so I go
alright I don't give a [ __ ] about these
I'm gonna take them down to this guy I'm
gonna figure out if this guy is any good
or anything and the guy fixes them
they're [ __ ] phenomenal so what I'm
doing is I'm gradually bringing this guy
more expensive [ __ ] alright now that's
what I suggest when you find a guy who
says he's gonna repair your [ __ ] start
with something you don't give a [ __ ]
about like a clock radio all right let
him repair it and if it works you're all
[ __ ] good right because I'm all about
this [ __ ] by the way is when something
breaks you go out and you get it fixed
because for evidently
there is a pile of [ __ ] in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean one-and-a-half times
the size of Texas and two miles deep of
all the [ __ ] that we just [ __ ] throw
out all right and then the Sun breaks
down the plastic as much as it can right
and it becomes these little cubes and
birds eat it and [ __ ] fish eat it and
then you go down and II go to some sushi
and you think you're eating healthy
you're actually eating your old [ __ ]
rollerblades so I'm all about fixing
this [ __ ] so this [ __ ] maniac he's
like really like eccentric his place is
an absolute [ __ ] mess and he was
talking about I don't give away his idea
here but I'm kind of gonna talk as it's
say he was talking about how all
recorded music since the beginning of
history is a [ __ ] lie I'm like what
are you talkin of conversations you have
when you go into a [ __ ] mom-and-pop
kind of place you know it isn't like
Joe's next can I help complains I'm
sorry sir we can't kids there anything
else I can help you with this guy isn't
like that he's telling me this [ __ ] and
he basically broke it down saying that
he works Monday through Saturday
fixing electronic [ __ ] and on Sunday he
goes on the Internet
and he looks up the heights
of like Jimi Hendrix all the Beatles and
he tries to learn how tall they are so
he can figure out where to position his
speakers and I'm like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about he goes look at he
goes Simon & Garfunkel
he's like Garfunkel was 511 Paul Simon's
like five seven and a half whatever
fiend-like knew their exact heights he
goes
but when they do the mix they mix them
like they're the exact same height so
he's trying to tell me that you got to
put one speaker at 5 foot 10 or 11 and
the other at 5 foot 7 and a half to
really sat hear what it sounds like if
they were actually in the room singing
to you and when you really think about
acoustics that actually [ __ ] makes
sense I know a lot of you are going like
what the [ __ ] but I'm telling you this
guy broke it down where it made sense
because think about it like if I was
staying if I was sitting down if your
ears were good enough if you heard a
recording of me sitting down or if you
stan is sitting in a room with your eyes
closed you could tell if I was sitting
down or standing up in the room because
you couldn't because of the way the
sound was hitting you but when I guess
when they record the [ __ ] they level
everything out like the drums don't
sound like they were behind the piano
player or off to the left I guess
everything sounds you know I'm too
stupid to explain this [ __ ] all I know
was the guy in front of me he fixed this
guy's he doesn't just fix your speaker
he asks you if he wants you to hook it
up and do it the right way same thing
with like amps and guitars and I don't
have the balls to bring in my amplifier
I'm trying to see if this guy's true but
he he basically played Steely Dan out of
one of this guy's speakers and it
sounded like two speakers if the sound
was [ __ ] unbelievable so once again I
don't know what the point of my [ __ ]
story was there other than [ __ ] robots
[ __ ] let me wrap this whole thing up
[ __ ] by an old furniture that has
leopard print on it because it's got
jizz on it guaran-fucking-tee
and if something breaks down why ain't
you trying to get it fixed speaking of
which the blinds in my apartment my dog
attacked them like 90% of them are ok
but I need some new slats can anybody
tell me where the [ __ ] to buy those
because I want to repair him once again
Nia wants me to throw out the [ __ ]
things and just go buy some brand new
ones and it's like well what about the
wait a fuckton to my
blinds go where did wait where the [ __ ]
to those go there will be a great
documentary you just throw something out
you put a microchip on it and you just
follow it you know if you could somehow
find the thing that ended up in the
ocean that a [ __ ] a tuna inhaled and
then go to the restaurant and just blow
sad it wouldn't [ __ ] work would it
you know what this podcast is like
there's a bad thing that comedians do
when they're not getting laughs and they
just think the next jokes gonna get him
a [ __ ] laugh and they and they just
stay on stage and they stand
I should have tapped out at 50 minutes
and just and just been like I've proven
my point that when I do podcast on
Sunday night as nice as it is that when
you come in on a [ __ ] Monday that
there's already a podcast waiting for
you at work little [ __ ] nice little
ribbon tied around it's just not as good
is when I do them after I have a good
night's sleep you know so there you go
overrated bill doing podcasts the Monday
morning podcast on a [ __ ] Sunday
night I'm not doing this [ __ ] anymore
all right
go [ __ ] yourself if you want me to do it
I don't give a [ __ ] all right that's it
I gave you an hour and five minutes not
have a hundred-percent mediocrity I
started off alright but I think in
general this one sucked a big bag of
Altec as they say in comedy business
alright that's it that's the part that's
the podcast for this week and I'll talk
to you next week on Monday morning and
you can [ __ ] wait for it their
country
okay
[Music]
you